some of them don't pass the physical
there some of them fail some kind of you
know screening psychological screening
some of them don't pass the the pst's
the physical screening test then you
show up at boot camp some of them don't
pass the vision test someone don't pass
their secondary medical screening some
people don't pass the physical screening
test there but but some kids make it
through all that
so they've enlisted in the military
they're now in the military they've told
everyone they're going to be a seal and
then they show up
to to
coronado
and you'll have
the first day of first phase there'll be
30 of them 40 of them just yeah i'm done
it's like crazy to think that way yeah
these are people that like
have been told over and over again like
this is gonna be really hard and they're
like oh i know i'm ready yeah i'm i'm
crushing the pst
i'm you know whatever they're saying and
they show up there and but day one
where's that bell because believe it or
not
it sucks
and well if you don't have the right
mindset it sucks yeah even if you have
the right mindset it can kind of suck
yeah yeah that makes sense hey man it's
cold water
people think it's california it must be
like you know baywatch any baywatch out
here son
down coronado silver strand
yeah it's freaking 43 degrees in the
morning
you're standing up with a wind chill
getting after it they people just
ringing out
bruh i'll take a cold shower every day
and sometimes when you wake up and it's
cold out i don't know 48 degrees
right you can feel that coldness when
you wake up and then you jump in that
cold shower it's like um
freaking imagine going out to coronado
in the sand way colder by the way and
then you gotta do it it kind of gets
imposed on you you do it every day all
day every day
the instructors know the little tiniest
things
that are going to bother people yeah
they they know it like
you know like your brother if you want
to know your brother you kind of know
what to do yeah yes sir
they know they know exactly what to do
and they know it in every different
scenario that they're going to put you
they know when the boat is on your head
this is going to suck they know when
they know when you're paddling through
the surf this is going to suck they know
when you start surf torture this is
going to suck they know when you've been
doing surf torture for this long this is
going to make it suck worse they know
they know exactly what to do it's been
passed down
for 60 years to figure out how to make
it suck a little bit worse
that's what they know
and they that's why they get
70 80 90 attrition rate yeah quitters by
the way it's quitters
well yeah i mean
well
you kind of said something where it's
like you know the people make this these
all these preparations they tell their
family friends you know
saying it publicly straight up and then
day one or whatever it's just
you know they quit day one the
their calibration for the word hard
right or adversity or whatever it's just
miscalibrated like way off you know um
and then so that's not to and the thing
is i'm not like we kind of giggle
because we're like whatever well you
can't you have the right to i don't have
the right you can giggle no you could
give it bro it's funny i feel like i
don't have the right to because think
about this as an outsider or as just a
normal person where
okay i know what heart is i know what
cold is i know what sandy feels like i
know what waking up early feels like i
know what lack of sleep fit like all the
little individual elements like i know
what they all feel like right
individually
and then and for a finite period of time
yes because that's the other thing it
they make you feel like this is going to
go on forever yes and it kind of is so
dumb
and then okay so consider all that as as
part of the recipe right then there's
these these kind of intangible
ingredients of this recipe where that
what you just said and then addition to
that the people running it
it's not that it just happens to suck
even though in a weird part of your
brain it kind of feels like oh this will
just sort of happen to suck because the
water the ocean water is cold it's not
just uncomfortable it's cold because the
weather's cold or sandy because sandy
just sand feels like that it's just it's
like that no on top of it you have a guy
who and it's engineered to suck even
more so it's not just like we're in a
shitty situation this is the adversity
of nature you know nature has a vote
whether it's not just that it's guys
it's engineering it's like the algorithm
you're not just searching out freaking
cool videos check this out when you go
through hell week
one of the moments of reprieve is when
you go into the galley right because you
get to eat what is
like like a moment of comfort yeah yeah
when you go in to eat tell you so you're
going to eat and for like the galley is
a it's a building like it's a chow hall
so it's it's it's got
temperature control so it might be a
normal temperature you know it might be
70 degrees yeah
and you're going to go in there and
you're going to eat and there's a dec
there's an okay chance that you're
actually going to be able to like take
15 20 minutes to eat so you have like 15
20 minutes of like no one's bothering
you i fell asleep like one of my few
memories of hell week i don't remember
much but i fell asleep like face first
in my spaghetti
because i was comfortable i was warm for
a second i was just like boom i woke up
in my spaghetti
so
but when you get done with
ciao they like immediately come and
start yelling and screaming get out
there but when you go out as soon as you
walk out they make you bear crawl out so
you're on your hands and knees right
and then as soon as you come out they've
got freezing cold hoses and they're
hosing you back down to get you wet
again and then when you they basically
have like a tunnel set up a bunch of
people with hoses spraying you down as
you come out when you get to the end
they like brush your teeth with a hose
so as you're so you stand there and they
spray a freaking high pressure hose in
your mouth
right
so it's a shock to the system yeah it's
a shock to the system
but but here's what's here's what's
funny
the instructors
they're outside
and they sit outside with hoses and
spray the windows to let you know that
they're waiting
so like you know
they don't even let you psychologically
rest they're like this is what's coming
impending dude so that's the kind of
psychological warfare that's getting
played on yeah on these people
yeah going through this training yeah
mental preparation right it doesn't
account for that kind of stuff and brad
that's probably one of probably a
thousand things that these guys do a
thousand things so my friend i'm gonna
obviously he's gonna remain nameless but
we know and he was he happened to be an
instructor and he had the put it this
way he had the temperament early on high
school days where he would do that kind
of stuff